There are no poor people in Cambridge anymore.
They're pretty much all gone.
And those were my customers too.
They needed paper, and they needed pens, and
I had lots of poets.
And they had to move out of the city.
There's no place for them to live.
Cambridge is beautiful now, compared to what
it was.
Let's be honest, Central Square in many instances
years ago was pretty dumpy.
And now it's cleaned itself up and it's looking
pretty good.
Kendall Square was a mess.
There was nothing in Kendall Square, and God
knows it's really looking terrific.
Even the Department of Transportation is going
to redo its facility, and I'm sure that MIT
has a lot to do with that.
So, it has a lot of plusses, and the river
is beautiful, but the poor people and the
working class people, they cannot live in
the apartments by the river, and that's sad.
You've got generations of families with history
in Cambridge, and they had to move out.
One of the last things I did as mayor was
to write a letter to the president of MIT
and say "we really need internships for our
kids.
We need our kids to have times, places where
they can work in the summertime, where they
can experience science directly.
And President Reif was very welcoming and
said that that was a good idea.
The challenges that are out there with science
education are tremendous in so many ways.
But for us in Cambridge where all the jobs,
so many of the great jobs are in Kendall Square,
and in science and technology, engineering,
arts, and math (STEAM), we really have to
work together to make sure that kids have
a ladder, a roadmap, for them to be able to
feel very empowered over being able to get
jobs in those really important fields.
I think this has been a terrific, terrific
relationship over the past hundred years,
and I might have experienced around twenty
or twenty-five of those years.
But I think that the Institute has been there
for Cambridge, I think that, obviously the
impact on our economy, on jobs in this community,
on education, I think those are all very positive
things for this community.
And, I think we have a lot more things that
we can collectively address.
I look forward to how we can figure out to
work together on issues affecting our young
people and sparking the interest in science
and technology, and making kids dream, and
making kids think about all of the opportunities
that are available to them.
And I think we can do that together.